that was the last interview before he
got locked up and I hope he stays locked
up what Andrew I love Andrew Tate you
interviewed Andrew Tate yes why why
Andrew Andrew gets the goat
[Applause]
[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and today is game
day so I had this whole idea that we
were gonna do this whole morning Vlog
um and I was gonna do all this stuff
like cook breakfast you know get out of
bed nice and slowly have a nice relaxed
morning but your girl is running late
you gotta go
oh my gosh don't tell Auntie we're gonna
stop for breakfast on the way don't
don't tell her so today we have the
biggest game of the season and I
actually flew back from the US for this
I wanted to stay in the US another week
but my coach wanted me to come back and
play this game and I'm still jet lagged
so I really only slept like three four
hours last night and now I'm playing in
a game I do this all the time though but
don't tell my coach I stay up too late
because of the show but yeah don't tell
my coach that's that's what you mean you
no I'm not gonna have coffee I know I'm
strong if I didn't break in America then
I won't break today I might get a chai
tea though I might need a little
caffeine
but it's not coffee he doesn't care this
isn't the healthiest thing but a lot of
times I wouldn't eat anything I would
just drink coffee and then go play a
game I would really recommend that but
it works and I am pretty good at
volleyball so I mean the results speak
for themselves I really wanted to make
breakfast this morning Auntie Jenny
would not be happy she would say that by
the time that we spent going to the
drive-through I could have just made
breakfast whenever someone doesn't do
their job and I'm like oh I don't know
Andy's like well I could do it and I'm
disabled
there's no excuse as far as I'm
concerned
and who'd also probably yell at me for
wasting money this morning
she's like you could just take the train
and he let me live good let me live good
okay hang on a minute I'm disabled
and I did it so what's your excuse
people ask me they'll message me on
Instagram or LinkedIn or whatever and
they'll be like oh I want to invest in
your business and I'm like what the hell
does invest mean like I don't believe in
Money for Nothing okay can I send you
money
and you see this there's no response why
because I just like I'm like what's the
catch but yeah so when people are like I
want to invest I just feel like there's
a catch like they want a percentage of
something and I personally I don't even
know what a percentage of something like
means okay all I know is I saw that
movie about Facebook right I saw Mark
Zuckerberg did
none of y'all will Mark Zuckerberg me
okay I saw the movie and that won't
happen to me it was good yeah no it was
chai tea this is tea
it doesn't count it was T it was tea it
doesn't count
I'm still coffee free you know Andrew
Tate tweeted the other day that he's
been without I think he like tells his
team what to tweet or whatever that he's
been without coffee for a month and he's
like there's no benefit to it hello yeah
I know I'm not moving okay see you bye
oh I didn't mean to I hope we win today
I hope I play good I just love playing
like I just loved being able to like
walk into a room and people just look at
you and know you're talented I don't
know I just loved the feeling of like
hitting the ball and you just putting
that down you know and you make
friends along the way would you consider
doing like a YouTube All-Stars where you
actually make volleyball for YouTube you
know how this sidemen have like a
football game yeah
oh my gosh a volleyball game but for you
too that's a phenomenal idea blessing
that's a that's such a good idea where
we could actually do everything I like
doing wow that's such a good idea I
never thought of that we should live
stream the game
we we try to but we're not particularly
good at live
at life that's where we need help if
only you knew the best live streamer on
YouTube
exactly
[Laughter]
really my girl
this is this is my man anyway this is
the material that is slightly um not
everybody's cup of tea a blessing
you know did Phil tell you what I said
too when I first saw her
I hope to God girl you're you're not
picking up half the uh half the audience
and picking up on Andrew take work now
she's gonna do a documentary on it yeah
Andrew I was the last interview before
he got locked up
no it's not about buddy I think he's
right I think he's right and well not in
this car please don't say that please
not in this car
you brought it up
for one I mean I'm so happy that we're
at a gunberg who he thinks is an idiot
approved the exact opposite can I
respond or not in this car
for the adults if they're concerned but
if he is trafficking younger younger
girls on the right team the girls came
the girls came out and said that they
weren't true some girls I wonder if you
have the same energy for the men that
they scammed out of money telling them
that they were gonna fly to them and
that they loved them and all this stuff
nobody cares nobody cares about the bed
I do but men shouldn't be ruled by their
dick neither should
women who are intelligent will take men
forever because otherwise they'll so
it's fair in Love and War but men are
ruled by that dick you know seven
wouldn't he be smart for making the
girls fall in love with him to like have
that isn't that the same thing no
no no it's the same thing it's the same
thing no no no no no no no no handmaid's
tail all of that
still gone every day if you're
trafficking girls I'm offended
stop it I'm just saying otherwise a dude
manipulating a girl and a girl
manipulating a guy
thank you
foreign
[Music]
off to the finals I think I thought the
game was good I felt like it was a team
win I think we should have beat him in
three but we won a five so it's still
good okay I don't actually understand
England volleyball
um I think we go to the finals are we in
the finals now okay well there's four
teams last four teams there's four teams
left now so we go to the semifinal okay
so our the semifinals are the last
weekend in February I would say to eat
better when you're younger because I
feel like I would be further in my
athletic career and work hard because I
actually was on the bottom team at my
club in high school I was on the worst
team didn't even get playing time I was
a benchwarmer on the three's team I
worked hard my senior year was on the
ones team and I got better offers than
some of the girls that were ahead of me
before so work hard you can beat people
out and you can't make it far
why are we taking the bus because no
Ubers came because we're in Essex so
there's no Ubers out here plastic's
acting like he's above the bus you treat
him too well and they just can't go down
usually I don't have a show tonight
because I just took the first two weeks
off that I'm back in England because I
just needed a break but normally I would
literally do a show tonight so I'd play
I would go to the other side of England
and I'd come back at 9 30 at night I
start my show like there's been times
where I'm running in and I have 30
minutes to shower change get ready I
don't really watch sports
I just like to play like I've never been
one to watch sports so I remember I told
Kevin Samuels that because I sold him I
played basketball too and he like named
some NBA player and I was like I don't
know who that is and he's like how do
you how are you playing overseas and you
don't even watch it and I'm just like
some people are goated I don't know
some people watch the sports some people
do it
I got some cupcakes don't tell Auntie
that's one thing that's unique about
Europe is you can be in the country and
you can still really get public
transportation to anywhere like they
don't they don't have that in the U.S
that's like that's a European thing when
you're a big baller
21 baby
21.
yep don't tell Auntie I played a game
today I burned off the calories
someone's potentially filming
her
[Music]
yeah so I'll give you guys a little tour
but we got the hallway here this is like
a
reaction area
oh my gosh I'm so hungry